In these times,
technology
is,
uh,
generally decreasing communication.
I mean real communication.
Um,
cell phones,
Internet.
There's a superficiality involved.
And also again,
a separation from the content and from
the person delivering the content.
Um,
people ask,
I don't have a cell phone myself.
People ask me,
well,
don't you feel that it makes
communication easier and better?
Well,
frankly,
no,
I don't.
I think that most often a cell phone is
used for superfluous conversation.
Where are you?
Is the most asked question on a cell
phone?
So who cares?
Does that make my life better?
If I know that you're standing on the
corner of Fifth Avenue and 18th Street,
is that communication?
Are we,
are we really communicating?
Are we connecting or is there something
in between us?
And is that technology that's standing
in between us rather than
[inaudible].